hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
one of the questions i get asked the
most is what is the best area to buy a
property investment in right now and
coming up to 2022 and it's like oh
there's so many good areas but in this
video for the first time ever i'm going
to reveal my five top areas that i would
recommend for property investment
strategies and honestly i didn't want to
put this video out because i didn't want
everybody stealing all the best areas
stealing all the best properties so if
you enjoy my channel please do me a
favor show a little bit of love smash
the like button it literally by hitting
like it doesn't take anything away from
you it doesn't cost anything to do it
you don't lose anything and it really
helps me out because this video will get
spread around it helps the channel so
hit the like button also if i don't
mention the city that you thought i was
going to mention and you're surprised
let me know what your favorite area is
in the comments below so
i'm going to start from um my least
favorite to my most favorite but these
are all my favorite because there's only
five
so number one is
newcastle
castle cannot be messed with right now
coming up 2022. i mean for a start
newcastle football club is now the
richest football club in the world which
is just crazy i went to watch the game
recently i bumped into ant and deck
while i was in newcastle and it's just
an incredible city
also when you're in newcastle streets
the vibe the energy is absolutely
electric i really think that newcastle
is going to become a much more on the
map type city over the next decade and
properties are so cheap there i mean
i've got i've got a friend called ryan
one of my students he is he's quite a
well-known musician and he bought a pub
in newcastle for 130 grand he's turned
it into a hmo it's actually just outside
a new custom place called gateshead and
it's now worth seven hundred thousand
pound he's made an absolute killing and
i'm just seeing all my students doing it
in newcastle so i'm really excited about
newcastle and i can see a lot of
potential uplift also the yields are
good so newcastle you're on the list
number four is
blackpool blackpool i didn't used to
like blackpool because my some of my
friends told me that it was a really
rough area so i always avoided blackpool
and a few years ago when i spent a week
in blackpool doing the financial freedom
challenge with glenn i fell in love with
blackpool as an investment area the
people are great but this is why i like
black ball
in blackpool
house prices are cheaper today many
parts of blackball than they were
10 years ago
it is completely bottomed out so the
house prices are cheap as chips which
means that the yields are really good
the return investment's really good
here's something to note in blackpool
though although they are regenerating
the area the council are spending
millions and millions of pounds in
regenerating the area so it's up and
coming it's right on the beach on the
seaside the closer you are to the center
the rougher it is so if you're buying in
blackpool be careful of buying really
close to the center so fy1 is the
postcode for right in the center it's
really rough
you want to be like a mile or two
outside um go at night before you buy a
house in blackpool visit at night walk
up and down the streets and see if it
feels safe at night there are some
really rough parts but i do think that
it's an up-and-coming area the return on
investment are absolutely fantastic it's
right near the beach
the whole seaside area is being lifted
up and regenerated blackpool you made
the list which leads me to number three
number three is portsmouth now
portsmouth is an area that i'd have
never thought i'd say for a really good
investment area however
a lot of my students
have been buying apartments or even not
buying them
renting apartments and i've been listing
them on airbnb and portsmouth is
absolutely popping right now for
serviced accommodation the apartments
are renting out for like three four five
thousand pounds a month
it's just crazy so portsmouth had to
make it to the list again it's near the
seaside there's a lot of tourism
it's a very nice area it feels lovely
the people are great and portsmouth is
definitely definitely definitely if
you're looking at buying an apartment
for service accommodation i just have to
say portsmouth right now in my opinion
is probably the place to do it leads me
to uh number four
i'm counting the wrong way i'm counting
the wrong way number two okay number two
which is the valleys the valleys of
wales south wales in particular
newport there's so many properties again
you can mine for like 50 60 grand um
hannah mills jamie higgs i just had a
message from jamie from newport who said
samuel i want to come around your house
and shake your hand i'm now a
millionaire
he lives in newport he's investing in
newport what's he doing he's buying
houses adding value refinancing them
there are so many
buy refurbished finance opportunities
and fixer-upper and flips that you can
do in the valleys in wales
love the valleys of wales i've got
houses there myself
definitely number two which leads me to
number one where is it at and this will
probably surprise you but my favorite
investment area right now for myself is
buckinghamshire buckinghamshire just
outside london i had to say it was
number one because that's where i'm
personally investing i have eight sites
at the moment all in buckinghamshire
that i'm working on and it aylesbury uh
just outside beck and beckensfield high
wycombe this is where i've got a lot of
my stuff going on even london itself
because buckinghamshire is just outside
of london
in the past i've spoken negatively about
london as a buy to let area but i do
think that london's exciting at the
moment and the reason is is because of
what happened with the lockdown
commercial properties took a massive hit
and prices have dropped significantly in
in many parts of london and i can see
london coming back huge and right now
i'm investing on the outskirts of london
in buckinghamshire which is i mean i
live just 20 minutes on the train to
marleybone so i'm really really excited
about buckinghamshire a lot of
development opportunities you can do
things like buy a house a rubbish house
knock it down and build a really nice
house
and make six figure profits and more so
buckinghamshire
london
i love you
great patch
most important lesson is this though
there is no magic area it depends on you
where do you know
what is your strategy you can make money
just about anywhere in the world
it's really important that instead of
thinking oh newcastle is the area and
just buying a random house in newcastle
it's better to find a good deal and
there are good deals in just about any
and every city but those are right now
the five areas that i'm most excited
about for property investment i hope you
enjoyed this video let me know in the
comments where you think is best and
where you are buying right now and i'll
be sure to see you real soon in the next
video subscribe hit like for more and i
think you'll really enjoy this video up
here as well check it out and i'll see
you soon